I do believe that this country was
founded on certain principles and I
believe we believe in the Second
Amendment. We are proposing on
self-defense our own position as relates
to the situation with black people here
in America
dealing with police departments one of
the great untold stories about the civil
rights movement was that it it required
violent resistance from blacks to be
effective the Huey P Newton gun club
gained national attention in the wake of
the Michael Brown shooting and the
subsequent Ferguson riots but club
president Charles Goodson says that he
and a small group of activists actually
founded the club in the summer of 2014
after learning that Dallas police have
shot at 40 unarmed suspects according to
their own records we attended a meeting
of the gun club which takes its name
from Black Panther Party co-founder Huey
P Newton
and we talked with historian Thaddeus
Russel about the long intertwined
history of the gun rights and civil
rights movements fact that we use the
gun is just a political tool as much as
it's a provocative thing I think in
these days of age when you have black
men and black women cetera and
twelve-year-old child's to being shot
down I think we living in profane times
the gun is a tool it's a tool for the
oppressed masses to rise up and throw
off the tyranny self-defense is a human
right you have your rights your second
Amendment rights if we are citizens in
this country then that applies to
African American as well black Americans
have been using guns ever since there
were black Americans during slavery
there were some armed revolts in which
slaves stole guns or simply used ones
that were given to them it really began
as a movement after slavery after the
Civil War during Reconstruction when the
ex-slaves were left to fend for
themselves in the south and against
rising hostile opposition to them by
organizations like the Ku Klux Klan were
formed during that period largely as an
attend
to suppress the slaves and stop them
from gaining political rights and civil
rights and their freedom the Klan at the
time was really the first gun control
organization in American history that
was one of their primary missions was to
disarm the ex-slaves instead of being
lynched in Alabama or are being lynched
in Mississippi somewhere
we're being lynched now in st. Louis
we're being lynched on live stream video
with Eric Gardner we'll being lynched on
camera with Oscar Grant and so we call
ourselves QEP news because of the the
platform that they took and as a relates
to the police there's no question that
you et Newton Bobby Seale in the Black
Panther Party launched the modern gun
rights movement we give credit to the
NRA usually that's not the case in
California night in the 1960s was
essentially an open carry state at that
time very loose gun laws and the Black
Panthers took advantage of that at one
point they marched on the State Capitol
with guns black men with rifles marched
into the state capitol building in
Sacramento in response to that bill was
passed which became the California's
first gun control law which eventually
became the model for a national gun
control law so the Panthers really were
the first gun rights movement and the
response to them which was by the way a
Republican response authored by a
Republican congressman and Ronald Reagan
who was governor at the time was the
first gun control anti movement when he
brought all the hardware back flap
standing out right we'll integrate that
back for that's the end of the day we
already know that errors the first line
of government is is your local
government but the police is only the
first person you're going to come in
contact with that's that that represents
the state whether I'm protecting myself
from a robber a rapist or anyone that's
trying to brutalize and murder me we
don't differentiate when we say
self-defense one of the great untold
stories about the civil rights movement
was that it it required violent
resistance from blacks to be effective
the dogs and the fire hoses were not
used primarily against the peaceful
schoolchildren who are marching
thousands of people showed up to watch
this nonviolent protest people who are
not organized by king or the SCLC and
those people many of them threw bricks
and rocks and bottles at the cops who
were there there were shots fired
several of bull Connor's police officers
were wounded this is all before he uses
the hoses and the dogs and in fact he
used the dogs and the hoses against
those people now if that hadn't happened
right King would have had very little
leverage to go to the the city elders
with but that's what he did in his
letter from Birmingham jail he said to
the white leadership of Birmingham he
said you have a choice you can deal with
those people in the streets and and have
a an ocean of blood at your hands or you
can deal with people like me you know
good peaceful Christian relatively
law-abiding citizens I'm not promoting
violent resistance but there's no
question that it has been effective
historically no UV noon gun club member
will
grants or money from the government we
don't want it no I'm nothing from
evening a person give you the expects of
the back one of the things about
accepting government grants is that we
feel that we should do for ourselves but
one of the main reasons why we say that
is because we feel that as long as we
control it there no one else control it
you can't buy us believe it now we found
supporters from all over the political
spectrum from the left over from the
liberal types to the more conservative
types and so we've gotten a lot of
response from the conservative people
and you know National Rifle Association
think groups like that we don't consider
ourselves to the far right or to the far
left we think what we're doing is right
on time you know right now we're seeing
in this country we're seeing a very
interesting moment when categories are
right and left or being blurred and you
see sort of people on the far left
joining forces with people sort of on
the libertarian right modern liberals
are mostly interested in social order
social control responsibilities they're
not of the left in that sense right
they're not a revolutionary force
they're a managerial force and I think
that's why they have been so eager to
portray gun rights as a right wing
disruptive racist cause right which is
just simply not the case what we want to
leave with our people and with the
United States of American citizens alike
is that we desire to be free we desire
to be able to practice self
determination and we will continue to do
so in so long as we so long as we can
know move forward